Bonjour les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Je suis très heureux de vous accueillir
chez moi pour un nouveau format
que j'ai baptisé "Bien reçu".
Il s'agit d'une rencontre avec une personnalité
que j'apprécie pour ce qu'elle est ou ce qu'elle fait.
Souvent les deux d'ailleurs,
connues mais pas forcément.
En tous cas, une personnalité
dont j'ai envie de faire partager les idées.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai l'immense plaisir d'accueillir dans mon atelier
quelqu'un que je suis
depuis 2013 sur les réseaux,
quelqu'un qui m'a appris pas mal de choses,
dont j'aime beaucoup le regard parfois décalé,
le recul, l'humour.
Ce n'est pas facile quand on parle de science.
Il porte le prénom d'une star de rock américaine
et vous l'avez bien compris, il a une manière
très "rock'n'roll" de parler de connaissance.
J'ai l'immense plaisir d'accueillir
dans mon atelier Bruce Benamran,
le Bruce d'e-penser tout simplement.
- Bonjour Bruce !
- Bonjour !
- Ravi de t'accueillir !
- Ah ba moi je suis ravi d'être là, ouais.
Dans mon atelier, l'atelier des Epicurieux,
et tu confirmes, c'est un vrai atelier !?
On est bien chez moi ?
Ah oui, je confirme.
D'ailleurs, je peux te confirmer que je vais pas partir tout de suite.
Ok eh bien écoute, installe toi, je t'offre quelque choses ?
Un café ? Un thé ?
Eh bien écoute, avec plaisir,
comme toi, sans sucre.
- Je préfère aussi.
- C'est du café quoi.
C'est du café.
Bon eh bien écoute, voilà.
Alors évidemment, les gens qui nous regardent,
eh bien... te connaissent.
Certains peut-être comme moi depuis 2013,
depuis que tu as créé ta chaîne YouTube "e-penser".
Mais on est ici pour apprendre
et savoir un peu plus qui tu es.
Alors évidemment, on parlait de cette chaîne "e-penser"
mais on va aussi parler de littérature, de bouquins,
de ton premier roman "L'ultime expérience".
C'est pas ton premier bouquin.
Il y en a eu d'autres avant mais celui-ci,
c'est ton premier roman.
Et puis, pour apprendre à mieux te connaître,
et bien, je vais préparer ici aussi quelques surprises.
Et puis, un petit jeu.
- Ah ! Cool !
- T'es partant ?
Ah bah totalement !
Bon alors, on va commencer
par ta chaîne, évidemment.
Tu l'as créée en 2013.
Pourquoi Bruce Benamrane crée une chaîne Youtube
alors qu'au départ tu te destines pas du tout à la vulgarisation ?
Ouais, non moi c'est en 2013, j'ai quoi ?
j'ai 36 ans ... Ouais, 36 ans.
Je suis informaticien depuis
aussi loin que je me rappelle.
Et moi à l'époque en plus, je connais pour ainsi dire ...
Je sais que YouTube existe.
Je sais que c'est une plateforme sur laquelle il y a des vidéos,
mais je n'ai ni la notion de chaîne,
ni la notion d'émission scientifique, ni rien.
Et c'est l'été 2013. Je suis en vacances avec mon petit frère.
Un jour, on s'ennuyait, c'était la nuit.
On avait fini un jeu vidéo, "The Last of US".
On savait pas quoi faire de la nuit, on voulait pas se coucher.
Et il me dit "attends, je vais te montrer quelque chose"
et il m'a montré une vidéo sur YouTube,
d'un gars qui est devenu un copain depuis,
que j'aime beaucoup,
Qui s'appelle Destin Sandlin,
la chaîne s'appelle "Smarter Everyday".
Lui, son but, c'était de faire idéalement une vidéo par jour,
mais en vrai c'était plutôt une par semaine.
Pour rendre les gens un peu plus intelligents
et pour se rendre lui plus intelligent aussi.
Et au bout d'un moment, je me suis dis "bon" et en français,
est-ce qu'il y a des choses ?
Et on n'a rien trouvé, du coup, j'ai commencé à râler :
"Ouais, ça m'étonne pas. En France,
la vulgarisation, c'est tellement compliqué..."
Et il m'a dit: "Vas-y, t'as qu'à le faire, toi !"
C'est comme ça que je me suis lancé.
Mais à la base, c'était vraiment un défi.
C'était en faire une.
C'était quoi ta première vidéo?
Qu'on peut toujours consulter d'ailleurs.
Elle est toujours en ligne.
Il faut s'armer de courage pour la regarder parce que, la qualité ...
C'est tourné avec un caméscope.
Le son, c'est le son de la caméra,
donc c'est vraiment ...
Mais non, justement, je crois qu'il faut la regarder
avec ce recul-là.
C'est à dire en 2013, c'est le moment où Bruce crée sa chaîne.
C'est sa première vidéo. Il faut la regarder avec ce recul-là.
Alors, elle raconte quoi celle-ci ?
Je pense que c'est bien aussi pour montrer aux gens
que même s'ils n'ont pas les moyens,
parce qu'aujourd'hui,
ça s'est vraiment professionnalisé,
les gens qui se lancent, il faut aussi
qu'ils n'aient pas peur de se lancer, même sans matériel.
Cela dit, la Terre tourne autour du Soleil.
Tu dis "on le sait tous".
En l'occurrence, tout le monde
ne le sait pas ou ne le sait plus.
Oui, ça, c'est un truc qui m'a un peu surpris aussi en avançant.
Et avec les années, en plus de me rendre compte
que non seulement il y a des gens ...
Moi je n'ai aucun problème avec le fait que les gens ne sachent pas.
Il y a énormément de choses que je ne sais pas.
Heureusement ! Et je suis très content
d'apprendre des choses continuellement.
Mais par contre, je me rends compte
que de plus en plus de gens
sont persuadés qu'ils savent d'autres choses.
- J'aime bien quand tu dis qu'il y a plein de choses
que les gens ne savent pas,
comme nous d'ailleurs, et que notre job
nous permet d'apprendre des choses.
C'est un peu le sel de notre métier, ça, d'apprendre.
Faire en sorte d'expliquer, bien sûr, de transmettre,
mais de faire partager et
de partager ce plaisir qu'on a eu.
- Ce qui est super important, je pense,
c'est vraiment que le grand public...
Je m'inclus dans le grand public !
- Nous nous incluons.
- Mais c'est que le grand public n'ait plus peur de dire "je ne sais pas"
et retrouve ce plaisir à chercher le "pourquoi".
Je t'avais parlé de petites surprises.
Il y en a une juste derrière toi, sur le buffet, là.
Donc on y va ?
Ouais ouais !
- T'es prêt ?
- Ouais mais qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être ?
Tintintin ! Hop !
Évidemment, tu reconnais.
- Oui, c'est une VHS.
- Voilà, à quoi te fait penser cette VHS ?
Alors c'est une histoire dont moi, je ne me rappelle pas,
mais qui a marqué mes parents.
C'est qu'un jour, je devais avoir 6 ou 7 ans,
et apparemment, je ne comprenais pas
comment la cassette faisait
pour sortir quand on l'éjectait.
Et donc j'ai démonté le magnétoscope.
J'ai vu des vis, j'ai trouvé un tournevis.
J'ai ouvert le magnétoscope et
j'ai vu comment la cassette, comment la partie arrière se lève.
Comment la bobine se tire derrière.
Puis ensuite, comment ça ressort.
En tous cas, il a fonctionné après,
donc je ne l'ai pas cassé.
Tu as un talent de pédagogue incontestable.
Merci !
Finalement, c'est quelque chose
qui te tient depuis très longtemps
puisque tu avais envie de savoir
comment fonctionne ce magnétoscope.
Ce qui est sûr, c'est que j'ai toujours eu cette volonté
de comprendre le pourquoi des choses.
J'ai jamais accepté,
qu'on me dise "c'est comme ça".
Moi la réponse: "c'est comme ça"
me fait toujours du mal.
Mais au bout du compte, quand tu dis que tu n'étais pas
destiné à transmettre, à faire de la pédagogie,
Finalement, tu avais un peu ça au fond de toi,
puisque la première, on l'a dit tout à l'heure
la première motivation,
c'est soi-même de comprendre.
Oui, ce qui a sans doute aussi beaucoup joué,
c'est le fait que comme, moi,
je m'émerveille de plein de trucs,
j'avais souvent envie de partager ça autour de moi.
Notamment quand j'étais ado,
je pouvais être parfois avec des gens
qui n'avaient pas spécialement
envie de s'émerveiller,
du fait de... je ne sais pas, des choses de tous les jours.
Et donc, il fallait parfois que je rende ça
un peu marrant,
ou que je rende beaucoup plus interpellant,
beaucoup plus intéressant.
Je pense que ça,
ça a beaucoup aidé aussi à transmettre.
Le titre "e-epenser",
ça, c'est un titre génial.
Et pour tout dire, j'ai commencé
à te suivre grâce à ce titre.
Moi, j'aime beaucoup cette histoire
parce qu'en fait, elle est un peu naze.
C'est qu'à l'époque où j'étais informaticien,
un jour, je me suis réveillé
avec cette idée où on était encore
sur la face du e-commerce et tout.
et je me suis dit "e-penser.com", "e-arriver.com".
Je savais pas du tout quoi en faire.
Je n'avais aucune idée, mais j'ai réservé
les deux noms de domaine, direct,
et des années plus tard,
vraiment genre 3 ou 4 ans plus tard,
quand j'ai commencé la chaîne Youtube,
je me suis dit que je devais donner un nom.
Et c'est là que je me suis rappelé
que j'avais ce nom de domaine, "e-penser"
et je me suis dit "e-penser",
c'est exactement ça.
Et il a fallu attendre le troisième
ou quatrième épisode de la chaîne
pour que je pense à la phrase:
"prenez le temps d'e-penser".
Parce que ce n'était pas venu naturellement
mais rétrospectivement,
c'était le meilleur nom
que je pouvais trouver à cette chaîne.
- On va se rasseoir ?
- Allez.
Il y a une question qu'on nous pose souvent,
à toi comme à moi,
au bout de toutes ces années, toi depuis 2013,
moi, un petit peu plus longtemps,
c'est "comment on trouve les sujets?"
Toi, comment tu trouves tes sujets ?
Il y a des gens, des fois, qui me posent des questions,
des gens que je peux rencontrer sur Twitter ou sur Facebook.
Les gens qui me posent une question me disent :
"Tiens, pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a ce truc, là?"
Et je me dis c'est vrai que c'est pas idiot.
Ou alors je trouve une réponse mais que moi-même,
je comprends pas suffisamment bien.
Donc je me dis ça, je mets de côté
parce que je vais être incapable de l'expliquer.
Je ne sais pas si ça se passait pareil pour toi,
mais moi,
il y a même des émissions que j'ai écrites,
que j'ai tournées,
voire certaines que j'ai montées,
qui ne sont jamais sorties,
parce que je ne suis pas satisfait
du résultat final
et que je me dis : il faudra peut-être
revenir sur le sujet plus tard.
Est-ce qu'il y a des personnes
qui t'ont influencé lorsque tu as créé "e-penser" ?
Alors pas au tout début, moi j'ai lancé ma chaîne,
c'était quasiment sur un accident.
Quand j'étais ado, les bouquins de vulgarisation
en français, c'était assez rare.
Ils n'étaient pas tous traduits.
Maintenant, il y en a plein.
Donc à l'époque, il n'y avait que
Hubert Reeves qu'on pouvait lire.
Il y avait Stephen Hawking aussi,
ça avait été un tel bestseller, qu'il était lisible en français.
C'est vraiment par la suite que j'ai découvert Etienne Klein.
Il fait tout ce que je rêve de faire,
mais il le fait sans notes, pendant des heures.
Et lui, à chaque fois, il va raconter une anecdote
différente pour parler du même sujet.
Enfin c'est dingue.
Mais bon, il t'aime beaucoup,
parce que je cite Etienne Klein,
il dit que tu as brisé les codes de la pédagogie
classique et que tu arrives à réconcilier
les gens perdus, ceux qui ont été brisés
par l'école avec l'apprentissage et les sciences.
Pas mal ! C'est pas mal.
C'est plus que pas mal, moi je suis ravi.
Je regarde les chevilles, ça va.
Cela dit pour de vrai, à ce moment-là,
ça a été une chance pour moi
quand ma chaîne a commencé à marcher,
d'être marié, d'avoir des enfants.
Ils m'ont permis de garder les pieds sur Terre.
Parce que je me connais. Je pense que ça aurait été totalement
différent si j'avais été plus jeune, célibataire,
je me serais sans doute pris pour quelqu'un d'autre
alors que finalement, je ne fais pas grand chose non plus.
Tu te serais pris pour Bruce Benamran.
Mais non, mais je me serais pris pour un genre de prophète.
En fait c'est un truc que je dis souvent,
et c'est aussi pour me convaincre, moi.
Au début quand ça commençait à marcher
la question qui revenait le plus souvent,
c'est : "Est-ce que vous êtes
un professeur 2.0 ?"
Je ne suis pas du tout un professeur.
Je n'ai pas la rigueur de professeur.
Je ne fais pas la pédagogie
d'un professeur.
C'est un métier, j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les professeurs.
Ah mais moi aussi, alors ça,
c'est un truc hyper important.
Souvent on me dit: "Ah, vous êtes le professeur qu'on aurait aimé avoir."
Mais pas du tout, ce n'est
pas du tout le même job.
Ça aurait été nul, moi je veux dire
“si vous m'aviez eu comme professeur,
vous auriez été nuls, on aurait bien rigolé mais vous auriez été nuls.”
Enfin je ne sais pas.
Pour moi, c'est ce que je pense.
Non, ce n'est pas du tout le même job.
Un enseignant, tous les jours,
il est obligé de refaire son show
et il le refait plusieurs fois par jour,
devant un public qui n'est pas forcément acquis.
Nous, on a la chance d'avoir un public
qui a envie de nous regarder.
Mais l'enseignant,
c'est beaucoup plus difficile
et je suis entièrement
d'accord avec toi.
Il faut toujours avoir
conscience en tête
que notre job n'est pas du tout le même
que celui de l'enseignant.
C'est quoi ta recette pour faire passer des choses compliquées?
La recette est assez simple et ce n'est pas
de la fausse modestie, ce que je vais te dire.
Je m'estime à titre personnel, n'étant pas quelqu'un
de particulièrement intelligent, je pense être un type normal.
Peut-être plus curieux que la moyenne, mais un type normal.
Et donc, pour moi, je ne vais pas commencer
à expliquer quelque chose que je n'ai pas compris
et je pars du principe que si j'ai compris,
c'est que c'est compréhensible par tout le monde.
Peut-être qu'avec les années, j'ai appris à trouver des formulations,
des trucs un peu marrants pour être un peu intéressant.
C'est pour ça que je parle toujours à la caméra
comme je parlerais à un ami.
Il a fallu attendre très tardivement sur la chaîne,
pour que je commence à écrire les textes vraiment complets.
Avant, je parlais, j'avais simplement des points.
Pour moi, la recette, c'est vraiment d'expliquer
les choses comme je les expliquerais à un ami,
et de pas aller plus loin que ce que j'ai compris.
Dans tes vidéos, il y en a quand-même
un qui en prend pour son grade.
Tu vois de qui je veux parler, c'est Aristote.
- Ouais !
- Qu'est ce qu'il t'a fait?
Mais rien en fait !
Mais c'est marrant parce que
j'en ai payé un peu les conséquences.
Moi, ça m'amuse hein mais j'ai vu
que ça n'amusait pas tout le monde.
Je me suis mis des gens à dos, des gens
qui ont pris ça vraiment très, très sérieusement.
Alors que j'y peux rien moi, si il a dit des bêtises.
En fait ce qui se passe, quand j'ai fait la deuxième,
je crois que c'est la deuxième vidéo de ma chaîne,
donc c'était : "Si je la lâche deux objets qui ne font pas la même masse,
lequel arrive en premier ?".
Je me rends compte qu'Aristote avait sa théorie sur le sujet.
Je dis "bon voilà, il s'est trompé".
La vidéo d'après, Aristote aussi avait sa théorie sur le sujet
et il s'est trompé.
C'est marrant quand-même.
Moi qui, pour le coup, ne suis pas spécialement littéraire.
La seule idée que je me fais d'Aristote,
c'est que c'est un des plus grands penseurs de l'Histoire,
qu'on cite tout le temps.
Il a sa propre école de pensée et je me dis plusieurs fois :
"je tombe dessus, à chaque fois, il se trompe."
C'est marrant, et du coup,
j'en avais fait un running gag.
Et c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois
que j'étais sur un sujet, quand je cherchais
d'où les premières questions venaient sur ce sujet,
neuf fois sur dix, Aristote avait eu son opinion sur le sujet.
Vraiment plus de la moitié du temps, il s'est planté et du coup,
j'en avais fait un running gag.
Mais par contre, ce que j'ai dit plusieurs fois sur ma chaîne,
il faut quand-même laisser un truc à Aristote,
et c'est ça : pour moi, le plus important,
c'est que quel que soit le sujet, il s'est posé la question.
Tout à fait. Comment est-ce qu'on peut imaginer qu'il y a 2500 ans,
il y a un gars qui se posait des questions sur le magnétisme ?
Alors Bruce d'e-penser, ce ne sont pas que des vidéos,
ce sont également des livres.
Il y a d'abord eu "Prenez le temps d'e-penser"
deux tomes, publiés chez Marabout.
Et puis, en fin d'année dernière, à l'automne,
au mois d'octobre, est sorti ton premier roman.
Voilà, qui est ici.
Voilà "L'ultime expérience" c'est publié chez Flammarion.
C'est une idée qui trottait dans la tête
depuis longtemps, écrire un roman ?
Alors écrire un roman, pas vraiment mais par contre,
c'est vrai qu'un de mes vieux rêves, presque d'enfant,
c'est de raconter des histoires.
Et je me suis dit tiens, je vais essayer, déjà, d'écrire un roman,
et donc voilà l'ultime expérience.
Moi, je l'ai vécue cette histoire, comme un film
ou éventuellement comme une série,
mais vraiment plus comme un film.
D'ailleurs, est-ce que ça pourrait devenir une série ?
Moi, je sais très bien vers où l'histoire va
et je pense que ça pourrait s'adapter en série,
et qu'il y aurait plein d'autres choses à raconter.
Il y a déjà de quoi faire quelques épisodes.
Il se passe un tas de choses dans ce bouquin.
On a parlé de bouquins, on a parlé de séries.
Qu'est-ce que tu regardes comme séries ?
Quand j'étais gamin, je collectionnais les VHS.
Depuis que le DVD existe, une collection de DVD.
Donc moi, j'ai tendance à re-regarder
régulièrement des séries.
Par exemple, il y a quelques mois,
je me suis dit : "Tiens, je me matterais bien à nouveau le pilote de Lost."
Puis je me suis rappelé qu'en fait, le pilote était en deux épisodes,
donc j'ai regardé les deux épisodes.
Puis je me suis regardé toute la série.
C'est une de mes séries préférées.
Du coup, je me suis dit que c'est vrai
que j'avais aussi beaucoup aimé Fringe.
Alors J'ai re-regardé les cinq saisons de Fringe.
West Wing, Community aussi,
qui est une série comédie quoi.
Pour moi, c'est l'une des plus fines
et l'une des plus intelligentes qui soient.
On a parlé de séries, on va reparler de bouquins
et je t'invite à grimper là-haut à la bibliothèque.
Et bien je te suis.
Voilà Bruce, un bouquin, je pense, qui va te parler :
Trou noir et distorsion du temps, de Kip Thorne.
Ça fait un peu peur quand on lit le titre et pourtant,
c'est un livre qui a beaucoup compté pour toi.
Oui, c'est une fiction qui raconte l'histoire d'un astronaute
qui s'approche d'un trou noir.
Et puis, j'ai feuilleté quelques pages.
Je me suis dit :
"Bon, ça a l'air d'être quand-même assez du langage parlé.
Il n'y a pas de formule mathématique. Je vais le prendre, on va voir."
Et c'est un bouquin que je n'ai plus quitté depuis.
Alors dans ce bouquin, il y a bien évidemment le contenu scientifique,
mais il y a aussi la vulgarisation des sciences.
Ah oui, mais c'est c'est un bouquin
où c'est vraiment tout ce que j'aime.
D'abord ,c'est un bouquin qui s'adresse vraiment au grand public
et surtout, ce que j'apprécie vraiment particulièrement,
c'est que ça raconte l'histoire de la science de ce truc-là.
Donc, c'est vraiment, on suit les personnages
au cours des années,
sur quels écueils est-ce qu'ils tombent,
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils se relèvent, pourquoi ils insistent.
Et c'est vrai que moi, tout ça, j'ai une vraie passion
pour l'histoire des sciences.
Ça, c'est vraiment  un bouquin
que je conseille régulièrement.
Je t'avais promis un petit jeu, un défi au début de notre échange.
Eh bien, on y arrive.
Je vais te poser trois questions.
Trois questions pas simples.
Je pense que les réponses figurent dans ce bouquin
et je vais te demander d'y répondre
de la manière la plus simple.
Ma première question :
C'est quoi la relativité générale ?
Donc la théorie générale, déjà, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
À la base, c'est une théorie de la gravitation.
Donc la gravitation, on voit ce que c'est au quotidien.
C'est ce qui fait que quand on lâche, un objet tombe.
La relativité générale, c'est le résultat d'une modélisation
beaucoup plus poussée par Einstein
qui voulait montrer qu'en fait, la gravitation n'est pas une force,
mais c'est une propriété de l'espace temps.
Mais en gros, la présence de matière ou d'énergie,
puisque c'est à peu près la même chose,
la présence de matière quelque part, va déformer l'espace.
Et ce sont ces déformations-là
qui provoquent ce qu'on appelle de la gravitation.
On va continuer à parler de l'énergie.
Deuxième question :
Comment expliquerais-tu en quelques mots E=MC2 ?
Si je devais résumer ça de la façon la plus simple possible,
ce qu'a montré Einstein,
c'est qu'il y a une équivalence
entre la masse d'un objet et son énergie.
Si on a une voiture qui est au point mort et qu'on la pousse,
on a besoin d'une certaine force pour la pousser.
Maintenant, si la voiture est lancée vers nous
mais qu'on éteint le moteur, qu'elle est au point mort,
mais qu'elle est lancée vers nous, et qu'on doit la pousser,
il faut beaucoup plus de force pour stopper
son mouvement et la renvoyer dans l'autre sens,
alors que pourtant, la voiture fait la même masse
et la seule différence, c'est que, quand elle est en mouvement,
elle a toute une énergie.
Une énergie vraiment d'inertie.
Et justement, avec cette idée de E=MC2 , ce qu'on nous dit,
c'est que la masse et l'énergie, c'est la même chose,
et que donc, un objet en mouvement,
ça peut faire comme s'il avait plus de masse.
Il y a aussi ce truc-là et c'est vrai que la voiture,
c'est comme si elle était plus lourde à déplacer.
Bon, ne le faites pas avec une voiture par contre,
c'est un mauvais exemple, il faut plutôt l'imaginer avec une balle.
Non mais ça marche bien aussi.
Ça permet une fois encore, de bien
se représenter cette idée, ce concept.
Est-ce que tu penses qu'un jour
on pourra voyager dans le temps ?
Je pense qu'un jour on arrivera
peut être à aller suffisamment vite
pour que certains voyageurs
aillent plus vite dans le futur que nous.
Parce que voilà, si on va suffisamment vite,
on peut aller sans s'en rendre compte,
Sauf que là ,où pour nous qui restons sur Terre,
il va se passer une journée,
pour ceux qui voyageront très, très vite, ou peut être près d'un trou noir,
il se passera peut-être une semaine, un mois ou un an.
Comme dans le film Interstellar, voilà.
Ça, c'est quelque chose qui est physiquement possible.
Le retour en arrière dans le temps, qui est, en fait,
le voyage dans le temps, qui intéresse les gens de la science fiction,
c'est ça qu'on voudrait savoir si on peut revenir.
Aujourd'hui, ça semble quand-même très, très compromis.
J'aimerais tellement que tout soit possible.
Mais d'un autre côté, ça soulèverait
énormément de problèmes.
Merci beaucoup, Bruce, de t'être prêté
à ce jeu de questions-réponses.
Merci aussi d'être venu jusqu'ici,
d'avoir accepté mon invitation.
Surtout que c'était la première fois
qu'on se voyait en vrai !
Exactement !
Alors on avait déjà échangé sur les réseaux
mais c'est la première fois,
effectivement, qu'on se rencontre.
Et comme je le disais au départ, c'est une rencontre très riche
et j'ai adoré ce qu'on s'est dit.
Avant de partir, je vais te donner les clés
du rez-de-chaussée de l'atelier.
Je vais t'inviter à y redescendre
et à me poser une question,
une question que tu n'as pas pu
me poser au cours de cet échange.
Je me bouche les oreilles et j'y répondrai bien après ton départ
sur les réseaux et sur ma chaîne YouTube.
- D'accord !
- Donc, encore une fois, merci beaucoup, Bruce.
Triche pas, hein !
Non, non, je me bouche les oreilles.
À très bientôt. Merci. Bye !
Salut tout le monde !
Alors Jamy, j'ai une question qui est un peu double, parce qu'en fait
c'est une question que je me suis souvent posée.
Et que je sais, beaucoup de gens se posent.
C'est que s'il n'y avait pas eu "C'est pas sorcier",
on aurait sans doute eu une vie un peu différente.
Je ne sais pas si moi aujourd'hui, je serais là
Et la question que j'ai envie de te poser,
c'est s'il n'y avait pas eu "C'est pas sorcier"
qu'est-ce que toi, tu aurais fait ?
Et ce que je vais faire maintenant, c'est que je vais fermer l'atelier,
parce qu'il n'est pas question que je m'en aille.